[Música]
boa tarde
meu nome é priscila esse aqui do meu
lado é o felipe e nós fazemos parte do
criciúma invisível e o que é o criciúma
invisível
alguns de vocês provavelmente não
conhecem ou então já ouviram falar e
quem sabe até a andar ou curtindo
acompanhando a página no facebook legal
os caras possam fotos de pessoas e conta
um pouco da história delas
mas por que você já parou para pensar
que essa pessoa do seu lado
qual a história dela já parou pra pensar
na quantidade de pessoas histórias de
coisas que você não conhece e podiam
estar fazendo a diferença na sua vida
nós já paramos e aí está o nosso porque
somos curiosos
o desconhecido nos move e de certa forma
ele nos completa ajudando a construir
quem somos ea nossa visão de mundo
essa inquietação sobre o desconhecido
aumentou em 2010 onde durante uma viagem
para são paulo a quantidade de pessoas
em situação de rua nos chamou a atenção
um senhor dormindo na escadaria da
estação da luz fez várias perguntas
surgirem e o porquê de ele estar naquela
situação nunca foi respondido
porém podemos dizer que ali se plantou
uma semente em 2014 essa semente brotou
e deu origem ao trabalho de conclusão de
curso da priscila que teve como tema as
pessoas em situação de rua na cidade de
criciúma a partir do tcc dela passamos a
estabelecer um contato maior com essas
pessoas e com as suas experiências
o tcc chegou ao fim em 2015 encontramos
na rede uma espécie de metodologia tendo
as páginas sp invisível e uma sorte
melhor como influências diretas
ampliamos a partir dali os nossos
horizontes encontrando assim uma nova
forma de dar continuidade a esse
trabalho a gente achou que era esse o
tempero que estava faltando
trouxemos essas idéias de encontro que
já tínhamos e assim nasceu o criciúma
invisível como conhecemos hoje
o que a gente fez a seguir foi vestir a
camisa dessa idéia
vamos para as ruas e começamos a
conversar e ouvir que as pessoas tinha
pra falar e literalmente jogamos disse
na rede
pare e pense em quantas pessoas você
inteira de hoje com quantas você
compartilha algo interessante outro com
alguma idéia ea gente nem precisa ir
muito longe
agora pouco mesmo aqui na sic quantas
pessoas você cumprimentou com um boa
tarde
imersos em tela smartphones tablets
notebooks onde recebemos novamente
constante de informações
será mesmo que estamos mais conectados
através das redes sociais
percebendo essa realidade através de uma
página no facebook buscamos levar para a
tela das pessoas e colocar na frente
delas aquilo que elas têm ignorado nas
ruas
o invisível que a gente aborda na página
são as histórias
toda pessoa carrega consigo muita coisa
cada ser humano ao mundo diferente de
experiências e vivências que a gente não
conhece não relatamos apenas histórias
de pessoas em situação de rua e à margem
da sociedade mas também histórias sem
rótulos a minha ea sua por que não
afinal a história de cada um de vocês
também visível para nós
bom agora que você já conhece um pouco
mais sobre o criciúma invisível
a gente gostaria de convidar vocês pra
saber um pouco mais sobre essas
experiências e de que forma elas estão
mudando a nossa percepção de mundo como
falta falou cada história dessa vai
complementar um pouquinho a gente e
mudando alguma coisa da gente a gente
vai contar um pouquinho então como isso
acontece
não faz muito tempo por exemplo a gente
sair um dia à noite para fazer um
presumível a gente estava na praça nereu
ramos e na frente da casa da cultura a
gente viu um grupo reunido por que não
vamos lá ea gente chegou lá e como
sempre a gente faz a gente complementou
pessoal e em seguida a gente começou a
apresentar o projeto
quando a gente fala em criciúma
invisível a maioria das pessoas logo
pensei ah
morador de rua àquela página trata de
morador de rua aquelas pessoas que são
invisíveis para a sociedade
tanto que naquele dia quando a gente
estava antes mesmo de terminar de falar
o que quer o projeto um dos caras que
estavam ali disse
assim na verdade mesmo morador de rua é
só eu eo jorge
esse aqui do meu lado ele é o rodrigo e
ele aguarda que na casa da cultura
bom aí que entra a nossa ideia de tornar
visível as histórias invisíveis
a gente não sabia por exemplo que o
rodrigo era guarda na casa da cultura
e aí a gente pára e pensa o que mais que
a gente não sabia sobre rodrigo
e foi assim que a gente entra nessa roda
de conversa
naquele dia estava muito frio a gente
levou uma térmica de café e alguns
sanduíches
a gente ficou livro com a história rindo
por horas e horas
e aí você pode pensar que a gente estava
fazendo um favor para essas pessoas ao
fazer isso a falar com elas ao ilegal a
café e tudo mais
só que vocês se enganam porque na
verdade são essas pessoas que estão
fazendo um favor pra gente
ao compartilhar tanta coisa e fazer a
gente perceber tanta coisa a partir de
vivências que na verdade são delas
gente que soma na rua muita gente que a
gente não sabia nem que existia vocês
aqui por exemplo a gente não conhece
vocês a história de vocês
o que será que cada um de vocês tem que
podia estar contribuindo com a missa
muita coisa eu tô perdendo eu não
conhecer vocês
um exemplo bem claro disso também é a
história do guilherme guilherme europa
em são paulo estava de passagem por
criciúma
a nossa conversa ele nos passou ele
tinha ficado desempregados 18 anos e
perdido um apartamento em que ele morava
foi aí que então ele decidiu meter o pé
na estrada e ganhar a vida como um
malabarista bom wilherm ele começa a
falar pra gente que quando ele era uma
pessoa que não era notícia de noé
ele tinha uma visão que como a maioria
das pessoas tem aqui de que por exemplo
um artista de rua no sinal é um cara sem
instrução nenhuma é que pode te roubar a
sei lá vem vários pensamentos na cabeça
e ele fala que na verdade quando ele foi
para o outro lado da moeda passando a
viver como artista de rua que ele
percebe o quanto isso também é um
trabalho passa é significativo e que
exige bastante dedicação porque ele fala
que por exemplo ele leva três dias para
tirar um truque que às vezes é de 10
segundos que ele vai fazer lá no final e
o que mais deixa chateado nisso não é o
tempo que ele perde fazendo um negócio
pra notar um pouco no final é que a
pessoa lá no carro pega e fecha o vidro
e simplesmente não dá atenção nenhuma
pele e aí que a gente pensa não tem como
não fazer pensar quantas vezes eu fui
essa pessoa que fechou o vidro no final
quantas vezes eu fingir ignorar aquilo
que estava bem na minha frente e depois
daquele dia
não tem um dia pelo menos pra mim que eu
parei no semáforo e que não venha a
seleção que melhor me deixou naquele dia
pra gente
acompanhe essas histórias que vivi essas
histórias
um outro ponto de convergência isso tudo
a gente nota que a família tem um papel
predominante no futuro e no ru muitas
vezes que a vida dessas pessoas tomam um
exemplo muito claro disso é o papo a
infância e adolescente com vai conheceu
na praça nereu ramos que venham para
criciúma justamente em busca de uma
oportunidade melhor para a família dele
ficou no senegal
é durante o horário preferido é
comercial e trabalha no frigorífico da
região e saindo de lá ele já vai para a
praça trabalhar como vendedor ambulante
de jóias é hoje em dia é um assunto
muito atual é o a questão do das
ligações até mesmo dos refugiados de
guerra é e sempre quando a gente
acompanha isso noticiário na televisão a
gente acredita que é uma realidade que
está sempre muito distante da gente e
conversar com o papa e é nos trouxe e se
essa ideia de uma casa só de um só e que
o mundo realmente ele está cada vez mais
integrado
cada vez mais é próximo a gente pode até
ter idéia de que o mundo está cada vez
mais próxima
mas as pessoas será que estão cada vez
mais próximas
bem no começo do projeto quando a gente
começou um cara que a gente vai falar
foi o joão
muitos aqui devem conhecer o joão nem
ele senhor que anda pela rua cheia de
cachorro surjam na verdade ele é uma
figura é pública pode ficar assim todo
mundo conhece e já trocou uma idéia com
ele
enfim se você falar o seu joão maioria
conhece vai conversando com ele disse
uma frase que é eu sou um homem mais ou
menos invisível e aí entra de novo na
nossa história
afinal você pode conhecer aquela pessoa
saber quem ela é
mas a história que ela traz com ela a
gente sabe
a partir do feedback que a gente tem na
página
a gente percebe que esse conhecer o
outro não é uma coisa assim que você não
faz porque não tem vontade a gente
percebe que as pessoas se identificam se
coloca no lugar do outro
de vez em quando até alguém vai falar
com a gente lá no box e falou assim ah
tem um cara lá lá no terminal
eu queria muito saber se a área dele e
aí a gente pensa
bom parece fácil né vai lá e pergunta
para que a gente fala que não é bem
assim
abri disso tudo né a gente que queria
administração desta página
coisa que a gente queira trazer o
feedback é que cada vez mais entre nota
é que a nossa sociedade o momento atual
a gente vive um momento de muito muito
popularização né em muito um lado do
outro lado uma idéia pronta a idéia e eu
acho que é assim um grande grande valor
este conseguiu notar que este pec é que
a gente tenha um ponto de convergência
na página todo mundo de todas as
ideologias de todos os credos de todas
as religiões é acabam um timinho
essa é bom a gente certa forma consegue
romper um pouquinho dessa barreira que
culturalmente nos foi colocado que é de
não conseguir chegar no outro tem uma
desculpa pra isso e por enquanto a nossa
página fazendo isso
ela tá servindo como um dos meios de
aproximar um pouco as pessoas de
humanizar um pouco o olhar para o outro
e perceber o outro como o próximo na
verdade e é aí que a gente convida vocês
através da página a se conectarem os
outros não só no online mas também na
vida real
a gente quer que vocês por favor parem
um pouquinho no seu dia no meio de tanta
correria a gente sabe pedir de vocês é
corrido de todo mundo corrido
a gente espera que você neste dia para
um pouquinho
um respiro e passa a observar um
pouquinho do que está ao redor
a gente espera é que você perceber quais
são essas pessoas
histórias e coisas que você não conhece
e que podiam estar fazendo a diferença
na vida de cada um de vocês mas isso é o
que a gente espera de ver isso na
prática vai depender de cada um de vocês
e aí você vê
[Aplausos]